move over shipping there's a new game in
town forget imagining which characters
should date today we're exploring which
characters could practically jump
universes I am ready Miko Rocket Raccoon
this comparison is almost too easy
we're not even sure these two raccoons
aren't the same person don't believe us
check out the facts rocket is spiced tea
his attitude is off the charts can you
think of another sassy raccoon that
never backs down
if Miko doesn't instantly spring to mind
you probably need to re-watch Pocahontas
Miko is outspoken opinionated and not
afraid of confrontation a huge
personality isn't the only thing these
two have in common they're both
extremely greedy rocket was a big fan of
money he'll do anything for the right
price so we're getting out and then
we're headed straight to yondu to
retrieve your bounty Miko may not be as
interested in cash but he doesn't live
in a currency driven Society Miko is all
about food from fish to biscuits if he
can eat it he's going to find it nothing
will keep this very pair from getting
what they want is this just the way all
raccoons are Miko and rocket are so
similar we can't help but wonder is
every ring-tailed critter so greedy and
full of attitude the creative minds that
wrote these characters knew exactly what
they were doing even though they're both
rude and greedy we can't help but love
them they're adorable and full of
personality we love both of these guys
equally and we demand a crossover ASAP
big hero 6 the adventures what's better
than an awesome superhero a team of
awesome superheroes no one can resist a
well matched team when heroes have
abilities that complement each other
their power is multiplied beyond
imagination
Disney has created a lot of really
well-balanced groups they knock it out
of the park with the adorable heroes in
big hero 6 the team came together to get
justice for their friend Tadashi he was
the creator of baymax and big brother of
Hiro standing around their giant friend
baymax they remind us of another set of
heroes it would be impossible to ignore
the similarities the adventures are also
a plucky super group centered around a
huge character the original lineup
included the great green hero the Hulk
both groups care about each other and
seek to bring justice to the world
fans picked up on an interesting tie-in
it hints at a crossover that were dying
to see The Adventures films have been
wildly successful when adventures
age of Ultron was released something
immediately stuck out in one scene Tony
Stark is scrolling through a list of
artificial intelligence programs one of
the Flies is named Tadashi could it be
that Stark Industries bought Hiro's
brothers technology we really want to
know The Incredibles x-men the x-men are
one of the biggest comic book franchises
on earth if you've heard of comic books
you've heard of them there are a ton of
reasons why the x-men have taken up
residence in the hearts and minds of
people everywhere like most beloved
heroes the x-men are outcasts they're
the underdogs we all love to root for
through the hardship of being different
there are some serious character bonds
there the x-men are really a family a
family born with extraordinary powers
does that ring any bells we can't help
but think of our other favorite family
of extraordinary heroes The Incredibles
are each incredibly powerful on their
own mr. incredible possesses super
strength and is ultra tough his wife can
stretch like rubber their kids can
create force fields and move at
ultrasonic speeds maybe Jack Jack seems
to be able to do almost anything they
all bond together over their differences
just like the x-men The Incredibles have
super powers and super bonds thankfully
for The Incredibles they found a lot
more acceptance in society the legal
status of superheroes is hereby restored
the x-men have been vilified and
ostracized at one point they were even
outlawed The Incredibles enjoy fans and
celeb status Elsa Scarlet Witch we love
Elsa we can't get enough of her we're
just suckers for powerful women Elsa is
the ultra powerful queen of arendelle
she was born with her magical powers to
control ice and weather she has a deep
and meaningful relationship with her
siblings her bond with Ana's saved her
life and her kingdom the comic book
world has another powerful woman in it
and it reminds us of the frozen Queen
Scarlett which is every bit as powerful
as the Disney Princess her magic has the
ability to bend reality where Elsa
controls snowflakes Scarlet Witch
controls events in time she can make gas
lines
explode or cause an evil robot to
short-circuit the power these two women
yield is incredible that's not the only
thing they have in common both of them
have a sibling that means the world to
them Scarlet Witch has a twin brother
Quicksilver when her parents abandoned
the twins they leaned on each other for
support they were raised by foster
parents but never lost sight of who
their real family was each other
Elsa and Anna have that kind of bond too
they lost their parents and had to rely
on each other for support these super
sisters have a lot in common
Rapunzel spider-man this comparison may
seem like a stretch at first glance but
hear us out both of these characters
have a tragic family history Rapunzel
was taken from her family as a baby
Peter Parker lost his Uncle Ben and it
changed him forever both of these
characters have grown and evolved after
their trauma both characters have a
similar look and energy to Peter Parker
and Rapunzel are both on the younger
side a lot of attention is paid to how
much heat Peter takes for being a kid he
seems to get pushed around a lot
becoming spider-man is hugely empowering
for him and totally changes his
personality he gains a ton of confidence
and even becomes kind of cocky for a
second
Rapunzel's youth is only emphasized by
her naive look she's been sheltered in
her tower so long that she hasn't had
much time to grow up
Rapunzel gets picked on a bit too these
youthful characters carry that vibe
over into their appearance spider-man
isn't your usual hulking hero he's trim
slim and limber Rapunzel also has a
pretty trim figure if all of these
similarities aren't enough for you how
about their favorite mode of
transportation both characters love to
swing around and perform acrobatic feats
Rapunzel uses her hair and spider-man
uses his web but the effect is the same
merida Hawkeye we're so excited to
include one of the baddest Disney
princesses out there Merida is strong
independent and most of all brave we'd
love her passion and talents for archery
she's obviously devoted hours and hours
to honing her skill her character goes
through a ton of developments throughout
the course of her first feature film
she hasn't always made the best choices
at one point a selfish decision ends up
hurting the people she loves she
accidentally turns the most
her family into wild bears oops her
story arc reminds us a lot of another
Archer Hawkeye made his first appearance
in comics as a villain much like Merida
he gained some perspective and started
thinking about other people he had a
change of heart and joined forces with
the Avengers he may not be a freckled
princess but he is an incredible Archer
who changed his ways
Hercules Thor every culture has an
ancient mythology humans have been
telling each other stories since the
dawn of time it seems like there are
some themes that never change no matter
where in the world you are stories about
strong men can be found all over the
globe there was a golden age of powerful
God's and extraordinary heroes in
ancient Greek legends the strongest guy
around is Hercules Hercules is the son
of the gods he was kidnapped as a baby
and raised by mortals his godlike
strength was known across the ancient
world he's often portrayed as a tall
blond muscle-bound Hulk scandinavian
myths are full of tall blond guys comic
book writers have always drawn
inspiration from myth and legend the
scandinavian god thor is such a huge
character on his own that he makes an
obvious choice for comics the comparison
between Hercules and Thor is pretty on
the nose
they're both huge men they share
incredible godly strength both are often
portrayed with platinum blonde hair both
even have a signature fashion accessory
Thor has his horned helmet and Hercules
has a sandals if you're going to save
humanity with your out release drink you
might as well do it in style right
Prince Philip Captain America up next we
compare to wholesome gentlemen you'd be
hard-pressed to find a comic book fan
who doesn't know exactly who Captain
America is he's handsome charming
principled and brave he reminds us a lot
of a lesser-known Disney character
Prince Philip is the down-to-earth
charming and humble guy who wins the
princess over
he also convinces his father to let him
get out of an arranged marriage to a
princess and marry the woman he loves
that's some impressive negotiation
Captain America is a man out of his time
he struggles to balance life in the
modern world with his old-fashioned
values deep down he's a chivalrous guy
he believes in the same thing that any
handsome prince does there's a certain
fashion similarity between the two as
well Captain America is
serious patriot he's decked out
head-to-toe and red white and blue
Prince Philip seems to have similar
tastes and colors he's decked out in the
same red and blue as our hero the
similarities don't end there both
characters can be seen holding a
gorgeous shield in Captain America's
case his shield is a huge part of his
character he uses it to defend himself
and as a projectile Prince Philip might
not throw it like a justice dispensing
frisbee but he looks pretty cool holding
it Maleficent hella
maleficents might be our favorite
sorceress a powerful female character is
hard to resist
there aren't many female characters as
powerful as maleficent her character is
deeply mysterious she has seemingly
limitless powers it's hard to pinpoint
exactly what the source of her power is
or if there's anything she can't do her
magic seems to adapt to whatever
situation she finds herself in we also
love her fashion sense if you're going
to be a terrifying magical beam you have
to have a signature look Maleficent
rocks a dramatic style with huge black
horns and a flowing cloak everything
about her reminds us of a certain
Asgardian who could crush any cat walk
hella is every bit as fabulous as
maleficent her silhouette is very
similar hella rocks some incredible
black horns too we'd hate to be stuck
behind either of them at a concert Halle
has a magnificent cloak to her magic is
even more powerful when she's wearing
this dramatic garment hella is so
powerful that she held her own in combat
against Thor not too many characters can
say that both of these striking women
are incredibly dynamic they would make a
terrifying crossover Ariel mara Ariel
maybe the most famous mermaid in the
world
everyone knows King Triton's most
stubborn daughter her obsession with
humans is iconic so is her fire red hair
if you're looking for a comic-book
character to compare her to Mara is a
perfect match Mara is the explosive wife
of Aquaman in her original storyline
from the 1960s she was mostly treated as
a supporting character riders have since
reinvented the character and really
focused on her own strengths and powers
marah's background story is full of
tragedy that's kind of the norm for
superheroes with her famous hobby Mayor
had a son he tragically died and drove
both characters
some intense story arcs Mara ended up
spending some time institutionalized in
her grief Ariel has suffered a great
loss - it's barely even acknowledged but
Ariel lost her mother she also had an
epic run-in with Ursula these two
aquatic women have one very important
thing in common they're both strong and
incredibly resilient each woman has
survived a painful loss and incredible
obstacles both they're married to the
men of their dreams Mara and Aquaman
have had some issues but what married
couple hasn't Arielle and Mara both have
the bright red hair to match their
personalities we hope you loved our
comparisons between Disney and DC Marvel
characters we'll see you next time
[Music]